- (speaking foreign language) Ding, ding.
Ding, ding.
- (speaking foreign language)
(laughing)
(squeaking sign swinging)
(upbeat music)
- Today we're here to build Legos,
without speaking the same language.
- How that's gonna work, I have no idea.
- (speaking foreign language)
I live in California
and I think it's a sin
that I don't know how
to speak Spanish yet.
- My parents are Dominican.
I had a time-period in my
life where I didn't wanna
speak Spanish so I lost a lot of it.
Once I got older I was
like no, I need this.
This is my origins, this is my roots.
So I practiced it over and over again and
(speaking foreign language)
- I'm from Manilla, which
is in the Philippines
and out of the thousand
dialects I speak Tagalog.
- Tagalu?
Let me make sure I say it right,
I'm trying to be respectful.
Say it again.
- [Male] Tagalog.
- One more time.
- Oh, it's heavy
- This is what were building?
(thump)
- Ahh.
- Who has time for this? (laughing)
This is not real.
(beep)
(bell rings)
(pop)
- (speaking foreign language)
- Oh no!
(buzzer)
(laughing)
- (speaking foreign language)
- Oh, okay. (speaking foreign language)
(laughing)
- (speaking foreign language)
- Okay.
- [Together] Okay.
- [Male] Then after a while
I was more interested in
the language than the Lego.
- [Female] Yeah, for sure because
I was just like, let's count.
- (speaking foreign language)
- Oh shit!
(buzzer)
- (speaking foreign language)
(laughing)
- Okay.
- (speaking foreign language)
(laughing)
- [Female] I didn't
understand, nothing you said.
Except for when like, you'd be like.
- (speaking foreign language)
[Together] - (speaking foreign languages)
(laughing)
- (speaking foreign language)
(upbeat music)
(laughing)
- [Male] I feel like
we got something done.
- [Female] And there
was a lot of high fives.
- (speaking foreign language)
(record scratching)
(laughing)
- (speaking foreign language)
- [Female] I feel at times
I definitely grew impatient.
(speaking foreign language)
(buzzer)
(beep)
- (speaking foreign language)
- [Male] I wanted to
flip through the pages
and tell you you do this.
- [Female] No way because
of the language barrier.
- (speaking foreign language)
(laughing)
- Okay.
- (speaking foreign language)
- I was definitely listening even though
I didn't understand.
So I guess I just learned to like really
pay attention to someone.
- (speaking foreign language)
- No uh.
I knew she was speaking
fast, but I was just like
I understand her.
- (speaking foreign language)
- Even though those sounds,
it was the first time
I was hearing those sounds,
if I just focused on her
and stopped worrying about
what I want to say then
I'll pick up anything she says.
- I know that I am one blessed
and two I'm so privileged
to be able to speak two languages.
I appreciate that and I will
continue to move forward
making sure that my
children understand it and
can speak it.
(laughing)
We built this one without--
- Yep.
- Without speaking the same language.
- Without the same language.
- (speaking foreign language)
- What?
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
(squeaking sign swinging)